so you match them out like uh so you do
positional training so is that would
that be the hardest versus like live
training uh open like starting from
guard I would say Mount and turtle
definitely definitely made me very tough
because you spent all this effort
getting off of bottom out and then you
gotta get on top of a guy in the at the
time I'm not that good at holding guys
down so they escape quick and I'm like
[__] I just tried to hold him down gotta
go back down same thing with a turtle
it's like you you start bottom Turtle
you're trying to explode get out get
away and then you know you switch and
this guy get up gets up pretty quick and
you're like damn I gotta go right back
down there's that constant Circle man
it's it's very tough but definitely uh
you know build some character on the map
what do you think is the value of
positional training in general in Jiu
Jitsu actually this one just interacting
with you guys it's not commonly done
it's just like regular Jiu-Jitsu gyms
what do you see because probably it's
not commonly done because it's so most
of the experience is just frustrating
like if you're evenly matched you're
basically frustrated the whole time
if you're if you're doing it right it's
a psychological battle that happens in
like the mountains turn around it's like
you know because you maybe you get close
to subbing a guy and or maybe you do SUB
them uh you know when you're starting
turtle and you're on their back you
finish them and then you get this High
Point and then immediately you got to go
back down to defensive posture yeah it's
very like it's emotionally like up and
down so it's hard to deal with super
important if you're one of the better
people in the gym because it just puts
you in positions you don't find yourself
in in regular training so I think like a
lot of uh if you're a big fish in a
small Ponder you don't do positional
spying you're probably gonna get exposed
in competition you might even look silly
in those positions so you really have to
force yourself to do it despite the fact
that you're giving someone worse than
you a position where they might catch
you so you have to sort of put the ego
aside
yeah that's one of the things when I was
training regularly of course training
with you guys it's like trivial but uh I
didn't work on putting myself in bad
positions when you get better and you
regret it because the the big negative
thing it has consequence it has on
competition is you don't take as many
risks because you're kind of afraid
for your back to get taken all that kind
of stuff that was me before I went to
DDS I remember I showed up there in that
old position I was like [__] this yeah
you better earn this position yeah
exactly I didn't really have escapes
uh I was a learning curve for me for
sure uh do you see the value in
positional training or is it just the
source of tremendous frustration uh yeah
I definitely uh think it plays a big
part and you know your confidence when
you step out onto the the competition
mats you know being confident that even
if you get put in the worst possible
situations you know what to do and know
how to work out of them
so I had a long argument with uh with
Taja Gracie when you visited and he
thinks malt is the most dominant
position
even nogi uh versus back would you is
there a case to be made for that or no
dude I think I think all of your
opponent's utensils their tools are in
front of them so like if you're on Mount
they still have you know there's a few
ways to get out now I think if you're on
somebody's back I personally much rather
be on somebody's back than flattened out
I'd rather have someone's back and then
flattened out boots in flattened out
yeah yeah boots and flying out so not
not even body triangle but just
flattened just completely flat almost
like they're a position in my way you
see guys get finished because they can't
get out I think that position is
probably the hardest position to escape
can you see what hodger's talking about
with Mom or C just that good at Mount
like he says that you might mean the gay
cross color you know I don't know what
did he mean this is controlling wise he
just believes that you can complete that
there's
he actually thinks there's more ways to
get out from the back of the nurse from
the mount prior to getting up including
like physically prior to the keeping
Escape
I'll probably agree with him but that
Kipping escapes so difficult to manage
it's the funny looking Escape we uh yeah
people have a lot of trouble it's like
super hard to learn how to do but then
once you learn how to do it the
effectiveness is just huge yeah it's a
weird one when did that come to be a
thing
they're pretty recent I mean I saw a DDS
guys using it first I think yeah who's
the first guy to discover something like
that this seems like a ridiculous thing
to discover yeah I
thought it was a joke at first so you
guys really doing this yeah
I remember somebody showing me like a
technique where uh like if you just like
walk your hand on a mat or something
like that maybe on a triangle or
something yeah yeah
and it's just like a funny Discovery
like as opposed to like trying to like
shove it in just like walk it I like
doing that to people but with things
that aren't true
you know what I mean I'll just tell them
this is a technique and watch him
try to work out if I'm being serious or
not yeah that's what you do when you
achieve Guru status they'll just listen
to you like you're Steven Seagal see
what they'll believe